David Boder: [In English] This is a record taken from...an apparently Spanish refugee, who was taking classes at the Schools of ORT, in Paris. She is being trained...in a profession or in a...trade and a...further thing she will clear up during this conversation.
David Boder: [In Spanish] Es el...julio 30, 1946...ehh...recordo tomado por el profesor Boder, Illinois Institute of Technology.
David Boder: Bueno Sra. Rudo, ¿dónde nació Ud.?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Castellón de Asturias.
David Boder: Hable un poquito más despacio, más claro.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Castelló d’Empúries.
David Boder: Bueno, ¿y dónde es esto, es muy lejano de Madrid?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí.
David Boder: ¿Sí?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Es en la frontera de Francia.
David Boder: ¡Oh! Es la frontera de Francia.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Cerca.
David Boder: Sí, ¿y cuántos años tiene Ud. ahora?
[first name unknown] Rudo: 37.
David Boder: 37. ¿Y por qué está Ud. en Francia?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Por la guerra de España.
David Boder: Ehh...y...que...¿Qué participación tuvo Ud. en la guerra de España que está Ud. aquí?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Yo porque...pues nos evacuaban pues había Franco del otro lado...y pues eh...tuvimos que evacuar por las bombas y todo esto.
David Boder: ¡Oh!
[first name unknown] Rudo: Estaba con la...republicana...¿comprende Ud.?
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y puesto yo de vengo aquí.
David Boder: ¿Y...por qué no regresa Ud. a España ahora?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, pero no tengo familia y después mejor esperar, ¿sabe?
David Boder: Aja. ¿Qué pasó...[Ininteligible]?
[first name unknown] Rudo: No tengo nadie...
David Boder: “No tengo nadie”.
[first name unknown] Rudo: No tengo nadie allí y es mejor esperar ahora porque...
David Boder: Sí. ¿Por qué...pasó...a su familia?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Ya hace tiempo que están...que no viven.
David Boder: Eh...¿No...murieron en conexión con la guerra?
[first name unknown] Rudo: No, no estos no.
David Boder: De modo que estuvo Ud. sola también allí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, también todo el tiempo de guerra estuve sola.
David Boder: Sola, bueno. ¿Y qué hace Ud. ahora en Francia?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Ahora, pues, estoy ahí en el centro [Ininteligible] pues...eh, porque yo tenía mucho reumatismo, todavía tengo, pero ahora estoy mejor.
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y yo digo bueno...yo...si puedo estar aquí voy...a estarlo, para ver si me curo.
David Boder: Aja, sí. ¿Y...qué trabajo...qué está Ud. aprendiendo aquí?
[first name unknown] Rudo: La costura.
David Boder: La costura. ¿Y...quiere aprender a coser?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, yo a mano sé coser, me falta la máquina, más práctica, para...yo trabajar después para...la gente, eh.
David Boder: Aja. ¿Y...eh...cuánto tiempo cree Ud. que le tomará para aprender?
[first name unknown] Rudo: No sé, me parece que son dos meses, ¿no?
David Boder: Aja. Eh...Dígame algo de la...guerra...de la guerra civil en España, eh...en la parte del norte...hubo mucho de...
[first name unknown] Rudo: Ah...Yo no he estado al norte, siempre he estado...soy catalana yo.
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: He estado en Barcelona siempre.
David Boder: ¡Ah! Bueno. ¿Y allá hubo mucho de guerra en Barce...¬?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, sí. Muchos muertos [ininteligible].
David Boder: Y...eh...¿Y de Barcelona Ud. movió a dónde?
[first name unknown] Rudo: ¡Oh! Cuando estalló la guerra yo estaba en Sant Cugat del Vallès, un pueblo cercano de Barcelona.
David Boder: Si.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Yo, claro, no ví muchas cosas.
David Boder: “No ví”.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Claro. Yo sentía decir solamente, y cuando se...calmó...la cosa, pues, después me fui a...a Barcelona con la familia que yo vivía, que hacía de cocinera, ¿sabe?
David Boder: ¡Oh! Ud. estuvo de cocinera en una familia.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí.
David Boder: ¿Y esa familia se fue adónde?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Se marcharon después...eh...se marcharon, tuvieron miedo y se marcharon.
David Boder: ¿Y adónde se...?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Se marcharon a Barcelona y después de Barcelona dice, ahora dice, yo...me voy a ir. tenía...yo cocinera, otra chica, dice ahora nos mudaremos, dice...
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Porque dice no tenemos dinero...y...
[first name unknown] Rudo: . . . mi marido no trabaja, ¿eh?
David Boder: ¿Y hay muchos extranjeros en esa...eh...?
[first name unknown] Rudo: [Ininteligible]. ¿[Ininteligible]?
David Boder: Bien.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí. Hoy...creo que van a ir unos cuarenta de aquí, de Paris, que están enfermos, ¿sabes?
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: . . . Eh...deportados, eh...
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y claro, el trabajo que hacían antes ahora no lo pueden hacer porque...debido a lo que han pasado y...muchos aprenden alguna cosa...y...un trabajo y lo pueden hacer así más fácil.
David Boder: ¿Y Ud. piensa quedarse en Francia, aquí...por cuánto tiempo?
[first name unknown] Rudo: No sé. Quizás que sí, porque como soy sola, ¿comprende?
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y hace tiempo que estoy fuera y no tengo nada.
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y si tengo un buen trabajo, pues, me quedo aquí. ¿Para qué irme?
David Boder: ¿Es la oportunidad de trabajo mejor aquí que en España?
[first name unknown] Rudo: ¿Cómo?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, sí es mejor.
David Boder: Mejor.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, mucho mejor.
David Boder: Aja. ¿Pero mientras tanto Ud. está con una...organización que los mantiene?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí. Había...Eh...[Ininteligible], [Ininteligible].
David Boder: ¿Qué es eso?
[first name unknown] Rudo: [Ininteligible]hay un centro de deportados, antes habían...eh...extranjeros también, ahora solamente hay [ininteligible].
David Boder: [Ininteligible]
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y ahora como muchos ya tienen su familia aquí, para qué estar allí, pues, se han ido a sus casas, solamente ahí va gente que no tiene casa que no tiene nada, hasta que encuentran...trabajando...
David Boder: Y...¿Y dónde, cómo pasó Ud. la guerra aquí en Francia?
[first name unknown] Rudo: [Riéndose]...¡Cómo la otra gente!
David Boder: ¿Y dónde estuvo Ud. cuando los alemanes vinieron?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Yo, à Corbie estaba, à Corbie Eh...Corbie y después me marché con una amiga a...Amiens.
David Boder: Amiens.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Amiens.
David Boder: ¿Se marcharon?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Eh...Sí, y à Corbie habían barracas, de refugiados españoles era una [ininteligible].
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y para yo entrar en una casa a trabajar, porque yo me voy, estoy cansada de estar refugiada, yo quiero trabajar, yo...esto no es vida. Y claro, yo entré en una casa a trabajar, y...estuve casi un mes. Quizás no todavía, porque yo tenía miedo de los alemanes que venían, y yo digo: “¡Uy! ¡Qué voy a hacer aquí!” Y yo sabía que en Amiens había una chica española.
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y cada día digo: “¡uy! yo quiero ir con mi amiga”. Y yo: “no, Ud. se queda aquí”, y yo digo: “no, no, quiero ir con mi amiga”. Y allí me quedo las dos, con mi amiga y tuve suerte que encontré enseguida...fábrica...trabajo en la fábrica de [ininteligible], de tres días.
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y en los tres días vinieron...los soldados y [ininteligible] y digo, “oh, là, là !” no tengo suerte, una vez que encuentro un trabajo y estaba contenta, ¿eh? Y ahora nada. ¡Ay!, sin dinero, sin comida, ni saber el camino donde ir, ¿eh? Y claro, dice: “dónde vamos”. Intentamos evacuar dos o tres veces, con...eh...no muy lejos los alemanes, los alemanes...eh...Amiens y los franceses en Cagny y nosotros en Bougainville ¡Uy!¡Qué hacemos! Las bombas, las ametralladoras, se sentían y queremos huir, eh...intentamos huir, y pero todo si que se veía fuego, y cuando se calmó un poco nos marchamos.
David Boder: Aja. ¿Y a dónde llegaron?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Con un carrazoncito como esos.
David Boder: Con un carrazoncito que tenía [ininteligible]
[first name unknown] Rudo: No, no esas. No esas. Un carro de esos de poner los críos, esas cosas, ¿eh? Y claro, y bueno, y nos perdimos por un camino, y ya anochecía, y llovía y todo eso.
David Boder: ¿La perdió Ud. a...?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Nos perdimos, nos perdimos las dos.
David Boder: ¿Y quién tuvo las cosas?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Nos metimos encima de un monte sin darnos cuenta, y no sé de que sitio venían pero tiraban tiros, o sea que si te veían te tiraban tiros, nos metimos en un bosque, y claro, se veía más nada, y yo: “callate, no digas nada, no digas nada”, la otra lloraba, ¿eh? Y decía: “¡Uy! ¡uy! nos matan” y digo: “no todavía no nos han muerto”.
David Boder: [Riéndose] Bueno.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y...Y después nos volvimos a casa, a casa, no era nuestra, no era nuestra, era la casa de los patrones que ella trabajaba.
David Boder: ¿Y dónde estaban los patrones?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Se marcharon, ellos tenían bicicleta y se marcharon de prisa.
David Boder: ¿Y dejaron la casa abierta?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Dejaron a nosotras dicen...después vamos a venir.
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y...nosotros dijimos ¡qué!, no van a poder venir, ¡a ver! si todo esta ¡no sabes cómo!...¿y cómo haremos nosotras? Y claro, hasta la mañana siguiente ya no tenías sal, para poner más patatas, ni hacemos la comida de nada...y yo digo, yo voy a mirar a ver si encuentro gente para ver si me he lanzado, a ver si yo me entero de algo porque tenemos que salir de aquí, ¡es imposible! Y claro fui por allá a [Ininteligible], si [Ininteligible] o au Cagny, si yo estaba au Cagny. Y ví una familia vieja que no podía andar y otra con muchos críos, y yo digo: “¡qué hacéis que no os marcháis!”. Dice: “si qué vamos a hacer con críos” y la otra vieja dice: “¡Ah, sí! Es que las piernas ya no puede andar me moriría con camino”...es mejor que...a veces...[Ininteligible]. Después vino un soldado y dice...dice: “a las dos de la noche se tienen que marchar, sino...”
David Boder: ¿El soldado francés?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, a las dos...sí estaban allí, todos, ya por...¡uy, sí!...¡qué tropa grande!...Dice “si a las dos de la noche os tenéis que marchar...eh...nosotros estamos acá vamos a empezar a tirar”, dice...o sino dice: “va ir mal, ¡eh!”. Y le oigo, y yo contenta, y digo...”mejor así no nos cierran el camino, ¿por qué no partimos?”. Y las otras mujeres viejas lloraban...¿dónde iremos? ¿dónde iremos? Yo digo a mi amiga: “mejor porque así nos marcharemos, ¿eh?” Y...nos salvaremos, porque no sabemos lo que va a pasar, nosotros somos extranjeras, ¿eh?
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y nos marchamos a [Ininteligible], a [Ininteligible], por el camino encontramos una familia francesa...y con su madre muy viejecita y dice...” si...si, me ayudáis a llevar la [ininteligible], esta que llevaba mucha cosa...
[first name unknown] Rudo: . . . “Podéis poner los bolsos que lleváis”.
David Boder: ¿Ellos tenían qué...una...?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Llevaba una mujer...su madre vieja.
David Boder: Sí, ¿pero qué? ¿tenían un carro?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Un carro de estos grandes.
David Boder: Sí ¿De mano?
[first name unknown] Rudo: De mano.
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y llevaban muchas cosas ahí porque era una familia de cuatro o cinco, ¿eh?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y claro, después yo tenía tabaco, y encontré soldados en...el camino, franceses, y dijeron si me lleváis un poco...lejos...pues...eh...Uds., para ellos es el tabaco, y ellos contentos nos llevaron un poco lejos de ahí, y nosotros también subimos. ¡Uy, contentas, nosotras! ¡Mucha historia! ¿eh? [riéndose].
David Boder: Sí, ¿y entonces adónde llegaron Uds.?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y fuimos con aquella familia hasta muy lejos, hasta que después vino el autobús y dicen bueno...dice, eh...solamente los extranjeros se...se van, los que se quieren se van a marchar enseguida, ahora, pues como quieren, ¿eh? Y es que la gente se quedó porque...trabajaba...era...de la máquina del tren, trabajaba, maquinista: “Y yo, yo me quedo por aquí porque yo voy a trabajar me falta dinero”. Y nosotros dijimos: “no, nosotros vamos lejos, pues, porque no nos...nos interesa quedar aquí porque van a tirar bombas también”, y...nos llevaron a [Ininteligible], y a los dos meses...quisimos venir a...à Amiens. La gente decía qué vais a hacer à Amiens, sabían que todo estaba destrozado, ¡oh! nosotros tenemos las maletas...
David Boder: Aja. Bueno, y...entonces...¿dónde se quedó Ud. durante la ocupación alemana?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Amiens.
David Boder: ¿Amiens?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Amiens. Nosotros nos detenemos...eh...
David Boder: ¿Y trabajaba en Amiens?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí...trabajaba, lavaba para una persona o cosía o...así, porque no encontraba trabajo, la gente de aquí ya decía: “¡ah! ¡rojos, rojos, no! ¡rojos, no!” decían, ¿sabe? Y sin papeles porque a nosotros no nos...
David Boder: ¿Por qué rojos? Porque...
[first name unknown] Rudo: ¡Ah! Decían rojos porque ellos asociaban...
David Boder: Porque eran españoles.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí.
David Boder: ¡Oh, oh! Entonces...¿Y estuvieron alemanes allá?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, había. Había...à Amiens estaba todo destrozado, había alemanes, desde luego.
David Boder: Bueno, ¿y los hombres españoles, los refugiados, qué hicieron durante la guerra?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Se marcharon à Péronne. Cuando yo estaba...eh...cómo se llama...eh...à Corbie pues los mandaron à Péronne, a todos los que no trabajaban.
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y no sé, se perdieron por los caminos y cuando vinieron los alemanes...se mataron muchos, dijeron, yo no ví, ¿eh? Y...yo digo...y yo me...arrimo con esta chica...y las dos...trabajamos y nos ayudamos.
David Boder: Aja. ¿Y cómo...?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Esta chica le cogieron al marido también prisionero...serían nuestros soldados franceses [ininteligible] lo cogieron al...como se llama...[¬Ininteligible] la frontera.
David Boder: ¿Y cuando regresaron Uds. a Paris?
[first name unknown] Rudo: A Paris, viniendo de...de Alemania.
David Boder: ¿Estuvo Ud. en Alemania?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí.
David Boder: ¿Por qué?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Porque me llevaron.
David Boder: ¿Quién?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Los alemanes.
David Boder: ¡Oh! Dígame, los alemanes la llevaron a Alemania ¿por qué?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Porque decían que era roja.
David Boder: Aja. ¿Y entonces...? eh...un momentito. Bueno, ¿por qué la llevaron a Alemania?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Yo no sé por qué me llevaron a Alemania...
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Eh...porque...decían que era roja y yo: “por qué si aquí...estoy en Francia y...yo no tengo que ir a ningún sitio”. “Nada, nada, nada”, dice, “vaya a coger enseguida o...sino la llevamos...”
David Boder: Sí. ¿Y cuándo Ud. la tomaron de allá?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y yo solía tener cuidado, y yo venía de hacerme rizado el pelo, un día tarde, ¿sabe?
David Boder: ¿Cómo?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Yo venía de me hacerme rizado el pelo.
David Boder: Sí, sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Me venía de rizar el cabello.
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y era tarde y me perdí, la calle, porque...está muy destrozado Amiens.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y me perdí, porque a aquella hora ya no había...luz, ¿eh? Yo no quería de terminar tan tarde.
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y aquella chica...¡Venga, ah! La chica se ve que aprendía, y nunca terminaba, y por fin terminó a...las diez y media.
David Boder: Sí, entonces la llevaron a Alemania...¿y qué les hicieron hacer allá? ¿Trabajaban?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, trabajábamos.
David Boder: ¿A dónde trabajaban?
[first name unknown] Rudo: Eh...mire, primero...a las máquinas...pero muy duro para mí, ¿eh?
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y después cuando veían que no podía, que yo...lo echaba a perder todo.
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y yo pensaba: “no, esta gente me va a matar”, ¿eh? Y yo...que estoy...digo...es que yo me sube la...sangre a la cabeza a veces. Y yo digo, bueno, voy a ver al médico. Yo voy a tener miedo al médico, pero que vea que ya mi temperamento está mal, porque yo he echado a perder todo, me querían ir a meter, bueno...eh...
David Boder: Aja.
[first name unknown] Rudo: A esos campos tan, tan disciplinarios, ¿eh?
David Boder: Sí.
[first name unknown] Rudo: Y cuando fui, y después me llevaron a...un campo, a un trabajo...si era muy abierto, tenía que hacer ejercicio, desde luego, pero no era tan cansador como los otros.
David Boder: Bueno, yo creo que nosotros terminamos otro día esto porque yo quiero saber a Ud. que le hicieron. El señor está esperando que me vaya...
[first name unknown] Rudo: Sí, bien, bien.
David Boder: Muchísimas gracias señora...